hello everyone and welcome
to biology quick comparisons
in this playlist we compare topic a with
topic b
which are kind of similar but very
confusing
so today's topic is antigen versus
super antigen now well super antigens
are not like
superman they are something different so
let's understand what are antigens and
super antigens
antigens are substances which can bind
specifically to t cell receptor or b
cell receptors that means
antibody so these are called
antigens now
notice here here is a antigen presenting
cell
which is a dendritic cell or a
macrophage is presenting
the antigen which is derived from a
pathogen maybe or from an external
source
to the t cell receptor and this
interaction is very
specific as a result of this interaction
the t cell generates several responses
against these bacteria and the nature of
these
response is highly specific and this is
kind of part of the
adaptive immune response whose hallmark
feature is the specificity
now super antigen differs from normal
antigen
in the future that it binds laterally
to the mhc's groove so in case of normal
antigen it
it is one it is bound to the mhc's
peptide binding groove and thus
displayed to the t cell receptor whereas
these super antigens binds to the
mhc and tcr in a lateral fashion
now this results in the activation of t
cell in a non-specific manner so here
you can see
due to a specific antigen there is a
specific
set of t cells which would be activated
but
here due to this super antigen
kind of many subset of t cells are
activated
at once in a non-specific fashion and
just to give you the number
approximately 25 percent of the
t cells in our body is activated once
there is a
t super antigen mediated
activation that's huge right and these t
cells are mostly non-specific which
creates a huge
inflammatory response in the immune
system
well we understand this part but
what is bad about it and how it is
beneficial
for these antigens and who produce these
antigens let us know about that
so whenever these kind of situation
happens these
activated t cell can secrete so many
cytokines that activates macrophages
dendritic cell and many other immune
cells such as n cells and neutrophils
overall there is a huge inflammatory
response
by the inflammatory cytokine secreted by
activated macrophages and dendritic cell
and this inflammation creates a chaos a
huge chaos in the
immune system so imagine this particular
t-cell is like a policeman
who wants to capture a thief now once
this policeman is capturing the thief
this interaction is very specific
but think about this thing when this
police man is non-specific
and is able to catch many thief the
thief of interest here
is kind of camouflaging so it's
beneficial for the thief
but it's confusing for the police man
that whom to catch
so this is the strategy that is taken by
these super antigens produced by several
pathogens
overall it generates huge chaos in the
immune system
which is advantageous for the pathogen
not for the body
in fact it is super harmful for the body
because uncontrolled inflammation
can give rise to symptoms like like
septic shock
so overall what we learn is like super
antigen
activates our immune system in a
non-specific manner
now you must be thinking that activation
of immune system is good for eliminating
pathogen
indeed but here due to super
antigen-mediated
activation the specificity component is
lost in the adaptive immune response
and that's bad for the body because
instead of eliminating the pathogen it
increases the chance of harming the own
body
as if there is a error in the detection
and specificity system
of the immune immune cells so
many uh bacteria such such as
staphylococcus aureus
they secrete staphylococcus enterotoxin
which are actually example of super
antigens
and it creates chaos in this system so i
hope you understand
what is super antigen how they are
different
from a normal antigen and how it can
create a huge chaos in the immune system
and thereby increasing the survival
probability of these pathogens so i hope
you enjoyed this video if you like this
video
give it a quick thumbs up don't forget
to like share share and subscribe and
you can support me on patreon by the way
my courses are also present in academy
so
using my code mp10 you can get 10
discount and do let me know in the
comment how you are liking the videos of
this particular playlist
and please post your suggestions thank
you